before the break we heard controversial
clinical psychologist Jordan Peterson
tell me this about Putin's nuclear war
he said that basically we can't win we
can't beat the guy because we're too
reliant on him for energy we'll form the
White House National Security Council
official Brigadier General Robert
Spaulding wrestling author Douglas
Murray and former adviser to President
Putin Sergey Markov all join me now let
me start with you if I may uh Brigadier
General Spaulding what did you make of
Jordan Peterson saying that he believes
we're too beholden to Vladimir Putin on
energy for us to get any win here
well I I do think that he has a point in
that Putin is not really going to be
beaten in this and I think it has really
less to do with energy and really more
to do with what we're willing to risk in
order to create a military Victory here
and I think you know there's a good
predicate for what's happening in
Ukraine and that is the Korean War so we
went back and forth in the Korean war
with an adversary that didn't have
nuclear weapons in China at the time and
so I think we need to think very clearly
with regard to what are our aspirations
and understand that this is a cold war
that will last for probably decades and
these this is just the opening Salvo
okay let me go to Sergey Markov in
Moscow an advisor to Vladimir Putin a
former member of the Russian State
Doomer thank you for joining me uh Mr
Markov you're on the airwaves this
morning in Britain uh saying that
Putin's made it clear he'll be ready to
use his nuclear Arsenal against Western
countries including against Great
Britain and that it would all be our
fault because we've been the aggressors
is is that your position
uh of course uh and of course
nuclear war as a normal psychologically
person and uh
very very normal psychologically and but
same time we can see this war in uh
Ukraine it's a lot of psychology and
irrationality it's more personal war of
Joe Biden against
uh I can explain why was it Joe Biden
that invaded Ukraine I must have I must
have missed that because I could I mean
I could have been saw that in February
Vladimir Putin
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question let's try and keep it
reasonable
as far as I'm aware it was Vladimir
Putin that illegally invaded a sovereign
Democratic country Ukraine in February
not from Joe Biden no no no you were you
lost the point
um uh Russia didn't invade Ukraine but
Russia sent troops to Liberia to ukrie
from occupation
which had been imposed by United States
to the Ukrainian people
Russia did invade Ukraine that's just an
undeniable fact Russia invaded Ukraine
it is discussions
foreign
stop shouting
Ukrainian people voted overwhelmingly
for democracy they continue to support
democracy they don't want to be part of
the old Soviet Union well they did no
it's just a it's a demonstrable fact no
no
uh in Ukraine all elections
2015 can be pacified right it was Terror
now dozens of thousands of people are
either a political prisoner and I'm
particular
the truth is
yeah your friends
we can't keep talking over each other Mr
Marco but let me say this to you
Vladimir Putin is clearly losing this
war or he wouldn't now be mobilizing 300
000 reservists he wouldn't have been
losing territory that he gained the
Russians are losing the war and that is
why Vladimir Putin is now taking these
Extreme Measures
no
what I've I've been putting what to your
uh uh uh to know if Joe Biden and your
Prime Ministers almost crazy I think
Buddy Johnson and this trust uh uh will
continue their time before against
Russia Israel could lead to the
irrational scenario where nobody will
control and attractive will have nuclear
war another Russians
the constant threats from Russia about
nuclear weapons are frankly pathetic
absolutely pathetic it's behaving like a
bully in the school playground Mr Markov
I've got to leave it there thank you
very much for joining me let's go to
Douglas Murray in New York Douglas
um obviously a ridiculous conversation
in many ways but what is your take on
the reality do you think no Mr Markov
we're done I'm so sorry
um Douglas tell me about the the
situation from your perspective here
we've only got a few minutes left but
where are we with this this supposed
conflict but it was obviously a war
well obviously Russia invaded Ukraine
earlier this year and what we've just
heard is very typical Kremlin propaganda
which some people believe and they've
managed to persuade much of the Russian
public to believe and others just doing
this cynically for cynical political
reasons but the interesting thing of
course is the the course of this war so
far is that it has been undeniably a
huge failure for Vladimir Putin his
forces did not manage to get to Kiev uh
as they wanted to in the initial days uh
zelenski and the Ukrainian government
did not flee it turned out that Russia's
Supply chains were totally inadequate it
turned out the billions of dollars
they'd paid for in a military Tech in a
tech tech system that was meant to allow
generals and others to speak on on
secure lines was surprise surprise
mainly money that had gone in corruption
and kickbacks like everything else in
Putin's Western didn't work and so
Russia has been losing senior generals
it's now of course not winning of course
it's not winning if you you have to call
up three hundred thousand reservists
um most of whom are going to be
completely untrained then of course
you're not winning the interesting
question though is this from the point
of view of the West how long can this
conflict be drawn out it seems to me of
course that the the dangerous thing my
friend Jordan Peterson mentioned this
earlier the dangerous thing is this
winter Vladimir Putin will be hoping to
Hive off at least one member of the
Western Alliance as the energy problem
gets worse into the winter but this
conflict's clearly going to go into next
year now here's the problem if I can say
someone we should all be thinking about
is Vladimir Putin's going to in some
sense lose this war but not completely
and that's not entirely a bad thing
because the most dangerous scenario and
I think we've just had one of his sort
of puppet blowhards that we've just
heard from the most dangerous scenario
is undoubtedly Vladimir Putin losing
humiliatingly because a humiliated Putin
is I think the most dangerous Putin and
that's why I think for all of our hopes
that you know Russia can be completely
thrown out of Ukraine and this illegal
War can be reversed to the status quo
anti all of our hopes of that the
reality is that at some point there's
going to have to be some kind of
discussion which allows Putin basically
to retreat as magnanimously as possible
you know it's interesting I mean this is
what Jordan was saying I don't disagree
with a sort of intellectual analysis of
this but just going back to the general
sporting for a moment that does mean in
the end that Ukraine would have to
surrender some more territory and when I
was over there recently that was the
last thing they wanted to do but is that
inevitable
well I think it's the same thing as I
said that happened during the Korean War
I don't think the South Koreans are you
know particularly happy about the
demilitarized zone but it's something
that we're going to have to find a way
to coexist and let this long-term
competition between authoritarianism and
democracies play out one of the problems
that I think that we have to come to
grips with is that we are pouring
enormous sums into China who is in turn
pouring enormous sums into Russia that's
not going to help us long term it's not
also not going to help us that they that
China owns a supply chain which is not
something that we had during the first
Cold War so we've got a lot of com
competing to do and a lot of work to do
and you know it's not just going to
happen in Ukraine General thank you very
much indeed Douglas Murray thank you
very much indeed